Apeka VHAP, Apeka WS, là hệ thống sách thường chính sách phyền tiến, được sản xuất mời BIAS y sâm
thứ 5-2 in không trọng mời hai đến nay. Với hơn 5-4 in qua được xuất sửn, Apeka VHAPS đã trở thành một công phy quan trọng trong các hoạt động quân sư,
măng lại hiệu quả cao trong việc tấn công buộc yêu chính sát. Chỉ vì sản xuất của mỗi quả Apeka VHAPS
sau động từ 2-2 in đến 8-6 in Weste, là một trong những hệ thống buộc ý đã nghiêm gái,
và hiệu quả trong việc tư diễn khác một điều thư trên khẩm đến đất. Apeka VHAP có một số tính năm ký thuận buộc choi bao gồm.
Đầu đàn, nặng một tý lâu gàm, mạnh mẽ và chính sát trong việc tư diễn một điều,
biết lất, dài một trải tảm bẩy mẽ, đường tính bẩy mời mời mời mời mời mời mời mời, khu lượng mời làm tý lâu gàm,
phù hợp với nhiều loại thường tịt sống khác nhau. Hệ thống rất đường, sự dụng lâu gó lây giờ,
bản chủ đậu cho phép điều khiển chính sát vào một điều. Tâm bản tối ra, lên tới 6 kilometh
lối với các một điều mặt dất và năm 1 kilometh lối về mời mời mời mời.
Phương tịt sống có thể được khóm thư trực thang, mời mời mời khánh bằng và hệ thống phòng không mặt dất.